ils sont les anges gardiens d'un
patrimoine non protégé l'association
pour la sauvegarde des édifices ruraux
se mobilisent pour que ce petit
patrimoine rural ne disparaissent pas je
reçois le président de l'ase et rue
bernard sonnet bonjour bienvenue
merci alors déjà quarante ans pour que
votre association comment est venue
l'idée de la cré et président fondateur
il vaut vallot été conservateur régional
de l'inventaire général dijon enfin pour
la bourgogne et s'était aperçu que ce
patrimoine était en déshérence il était
menacée mais qui ne pouvait pas être
protégé au titre des monuments
historiques donc il a eu cette idée
on peut qualifier de vraiment génial et
surtout très en avance pour l'époque
pour protéger ce petit patrimoine qu'est
ce qu'on entend exactement par petit
patrimoine rural c'est tout le petit
patrimoine ce qu'on rencontre dans nos
villages les lavoirs les croix de chemin
les fours à pain des halles des mêmes
des murs des murs en pierres sèches ça
peut paraître banal maintenant mais
c'est quand même un patrimoine important
qui a structuré la vie des villages
depuis des millénaires
alors votre association accompagne l
aide financièrement les propriétaires
privés ou publics à préserver ce
patrimoine
exemple avec la restauration d'un mur à
abeilles dans le village de lantenay on
regarde le reportage
ce mur situé au fond d'un jardin peut
sembler bien commun et pourtant il
s'agit d'un mur à abeilles datant du
xviiie siècle
un bel exemple du patrimoine rural
bourguignon il y a deux ans les époux
ducret propriétaire des lieux décide de
restaurer l'édifice alors en ruines
j'ai découvert que ce mur s'appelait en
fait un mur à pied c'est un mur des
abeilles dans lesquelles les apiculteurs
amateurs les cultivateurs puisque ici
c'est ce sont des anciennes petite
fermette de petits vignerons ans
cultivateur pouvait avoir leurs ruches à
domicile et de cette manière là exposé
plein sud est et protéger du vent
pouvait garder leurs ruches toute
l'année la restauration s'est fait en
deux étapes 2014 restauration des
maçonneries du support de la
construction de ce mur qui sait boulet
en partie avec les poutres et en 2016
restauration de la toiture à deux
versants avec de la l'âge de
récupération coût total des travaux
18000 euros
les propriétaires devraient percevoir
une petite tête de l'az et rue 21
cette association de passionnés
accompagne depuis quarante ans
maintenant les propriétaires privés mais
aussi publics dans la restauration de
petit patrimoine rural l'avoir qu'abbott
fontaine moulin ou calvaire au total ils
ont soutenu 150 réalisation en côte d'or
le but initial de l'association
s'étaient de s'intéresser au petit
patrimoine rural délaissé en ruine
parfois et et comportant des aspects
architecturaux historiques remarquables
dans tout le département de la côte d'or
et pour lesquels pour lequel
officiellement il n'y avait absolument
aucune aide possible
l'azéri 21 compte aujourd'hui 200
membres
et si l'association fait naturellement
appel aux dons et aux subventions
elle cherche également à grossir les
rangs de ses adhérents alors bernard
senet vous recherchez des adhérents vous
manquez de monde dans votre association
on n'a jamais assez une association a
besoin de ces c'est vital pour exister
d'adhérents de feu puisque je rappelle
que c'est nos ressources proviennent
essentiellement des adhésions nous avons
une aide d'une petite tête du conseil
départemental enfin j'espère qu'il
continuera par les temps qui courent
mais c'est essentiellement sur les
associés les années les adhésions que
nous comptons bien sûr alors
l'accompagnement il se fait surtout
c'est d'abord du conseil mais c'est
aussi financier expliquez-nous un petit
peu comment ça fonctionne vous dire que
nous avons et co2
de besoin par ce soit par le bouche à
oreille par des adhérents ou par les
communes directement c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je vous remercie
effectivement que les médias ont quand
même un rôle important dans la diffusion
de cette information est donc que nous
allons sur le terrain nous donnons les
conseils avec nous rencontrons les
entreprises puisque le but aussi c'est
de faire travailler des associations au
des associations comme sentiers par
exemple pour ne pas citer association de
réinsertion mais aussi des artisans du
patrimoine donc pour pouvoir réhabiliter
comme il convient ce type de bâtiment
nous avons des primes qui sont qui sont
prévues des versements de primes alors
c'est à quelle hauteur de 1000 à 2000
euros parce qu'on estime
qu'effectivement il faut un coup de
pouce décisif pour pouvoir remporter le
l'adhésion parfois un peu réticents du
conseil des pubs municipal c'est bien
évident que le conseil municipal décide
parfois engagé des travaux importants
pour un bâtiment qui n'est pas plus
tellement d' usage
donc on espère qu effectivement nos
primes permettent de justement de
favoriser cette prise de distance mais
parfois complétée avec une aide aussi de
la fondation du patrimoine
c'était un complément oui c'est
évidemment c'est ces primes sont tout à
fait compatibles avec d'autres d'autres
primes en particulier donc on travaille
en liaison aussi avec la fondation du
patrimoine et d'autres associations
locales qui sont nés pour la cause
locale de la restauration de leur petit
patrimoine
ce retrait le critère vous déterminez
les projets que vous lancez les critères
de qualité d'ancienneté évidemment et
puis de représentativité ont une
sélection il ya le monde on aux billets
non une typologie qui a été dressé par
l'émissaire la culture il ya déjà pas
mal d'années qui est disponible
d'ailleurs sur la base
meriem et donc du mystère la culture
donc que ce soit l'architecturé
domestique larchitecture propre à l'eau
etc enfin ou agricoles donc et ensuite
on juge fictivement sur pièce
quel est le bilan de ses 40 ans autour
de 150 réalisation c'est satisfaisant
pour vous ai encore beaucoup de travail
il ya du travail oui c'est jamais
satisfaisant non plus m enfin mais on va
pas se reposer sur nos lauriers
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que fictivement
on espère que cette association
continuera encore longtemps qu'on
abordera peut-être le 50e anniversaire
mais je pense qu'effectivement il ya
encore du travail et mais ce qui nous
fait plaisir c'est effectivement que les
communes sont enfin les communes parce
qu'on s'adresse non seulement commune
mais je rappelle aussi à des
propriétaires privés
bien sûr donc jan sikken satisfaction
vient de beaucoup d'heures par y en a
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses à faire
merci à vous bernard sonnet c'est un
nouveau cd